[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
am 22 oktober 1985 ertönen im
italienischen torekanne kurz
nacheinander zwei Schüsse sie verlaufen
sich aber in Wellen und Herbstwind denn
der kleine Ort bei Brindisi hat zwar
eine typisch italienische dicht bebaute
Altstadt aber auch einen breiten
weitläufigen Sandstrand genauso wie an
der Ostsee an diesem Strand werden
schließlich zwei Leichen gefunden die
das vierjährigen Gabriel pölke aus dem
zu Backnang gehörenden dorfstrümpfelbach
in Baden-Württemberg und die seines
Vaters Norbert einem 34 Jahre alten
Polizisten die sich herausstellt hat
dieser Norbert pölke der jetzt tot am
Strand liegt eine gute Woche vorher zu
Hause in Deutschland seine Frau Ingeborg
den sieben Jahre alten Sohn Adrian und
den Familienhund erschossen das hier ist
das Ende eines falls der als der Hammer
Mörder schlagsahnte obwohl der Begriff
eigentlich in die Irre führt
hallo und herzlich Willkommen mein Name
ist Mirko Kasimir und ich bin Toni Heyer
hallo wir erzählen euch diese
dramatische Geschichte von Anfang an sie
beginnt mit zwei Faktoren die leider in
sehr vielen Geschichten vorkommen und
zwar Diskriminierung und kaputte
Beziehungen das Ehepaar Völker Norberts
Eltern kommen nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
als Flüchtlinge aus Ostpreußen nach
Baden-Württemberg ihr Sohn Norbert der
1951 zur Welt kommt und seine Schwester
wachsen im schwäbischen Geisingen auf
dort werden sie wie viele andere Kinder
aus Flüchtlingsfamilien ausgegrenzt
damals sind ja Millionen Menschen aus
Ostpreußen oder auch Böhmen vertrieben
worden und nach Deutschland geflogen das
war eine riesige ethnische Säuberung und
obwohl das alles Deutsche waren wurden
sie bei uns noch jahrelang als Menschen
zweiter Klasse behandelt auch die
Perücke Kinder erleben diese Ausgrenzung
Eltern anderer Kinder aus dem Arzt sehen
es nicht gern Arbeit und seine Schwester
mit ihnen spielen es heißt später
Norbert habe mit waghalsigen Mutproben
zeigen wollen dass ein ganzer Kerl ist
vielleicht spielt dabei auch eine Rolle
dass er wegen einer leichten Behinderung
einen auffälligen Gang hat noch
komplizierter wird das Leben der Kinder
als die Eltern sich 1968 scheiden lassen
die Kinder ziehen mit der Mutter in das
Dorf Strümpfelbach das zu Backnang
gehört einer Stadt 30 Kilometer
nordöstlich von Stuttgart Norbert fängt
beim Baumaschinenhersteller kälbler eine
Ausbildung als Industriekaufmann an ich
würde sagen semi erfolgreich denn er
fehlt mir einfach unentschuldigt und
wird daraufhin gefeuert dafür läuft es
beim nächsten Anlauf besser Norbert
pölker bewirbt sich an der Polizeischule
in Stuttgart wird angenommen und besteht
er wird Polizeiobermeister im mittleren
Dienst überhaupt beginnt hier eine Zeit
in der es endlich mal läuft im Leben von
Norbert pölke in Stuttgart lernt er auch
seine Frau Ingeborg kennen die beiden
bekommen insgesamt drei Kinder zwei
Jungs und eine Tochter und pölke gewinnt
im Lotto
36.000 Mark
das Geld fließt in den Bau eines Hauses
und zwar in Strümpfelbach wo Norbert
schon mit Mutter und Schwester gewohnt
hat auf die vermeintlich guten Zeiten
Folgen schon bald düstere Zeiten denn
mit dem Bau und der Einrichtung hat das
Paar sich komplett übernommen die Raten
für alles zusammen sind viel zu hoch
ständig ist am Monatsende das Geld total
knapp und 1984 erkrankt dann Tochter
Cordula an einem Hirntumor Norbert hofft
so sehr dass eine private
Spezialbehandlung sie vielleicht retten
könnte aber dafür ist ja kein Geld da
Cordula stirbt im Alter von nur vier
Jahren
viele unserer Kriminalfälle die wir hier
besprechen die haben den einen den
entscheidenden Wendepunkt bei
hammermörder Norbert pölke wird der wohl
jetzt eingetreten sein 1984
die süße kleine Tochter ist tot das
Portemonnaie ständig leer der Polizist
mit dem gehfehler der oft gehänselte
flüchtlingssohn mit den Geldsorgen
trifft eine fatale Entscheidung die
folgenden Geschehnisse sind sehr gut und
detailliert aufgeschrieben in der
Ludwigsburger Kreiszeitung und der
Stuttgarter Zeitung die Links dazu die
haben wir euch in die Show Notes gepackt
an einem Donnerstag im Mai 1984 ist der
47-Jährige Ingenieur Siegfried P mit
seinem weißen Auto auf Außendienst im
Raum Ludwigsburg unterwegs wo er
verschiedene Kunden besucht er macht auf
einem Waldparkplatz Pause als Norbert
pölke mit einer Pistole auf ihn zukommt
und ihm ins Gesicht schießt es ist
wirklich schwer zu verstehen aber pölke
hat diesen Mann nur getötet um sich den
weißen BMW 520i mit erschaffenburger
Kennzeichen zu nehmen mit dem fährt er
am Mittag bei der Volksbank in
Erbstetten vor er geht mit einem
Vorschlaghammer in den schalteraum hier
gibt es zu diesem Zeitpunkt nur einen
Angestellten der drückt noch schnell den
Alarmknopf und rettet sich dann in einen
Nebenraum zerstört mit dem Hammer die
Scheibe zum Kassenraum stoppt die
Tageskasse in eine Tasche und fliegt
aber der Überfall war eine Pleite es
waren nur knapp 4.800 Mark in der Kasse
und Völker hat sich an der Hand verletzt
und Blutspuren hinterlassen in der
Region ist man natürlich schockiert da
hat einer jemanden erschossen nur um das
Auto zu nehmen und dann in der Bank
gewütet wie ein Wahnsinniger
wochenlang werden die Parkplätze im Raum
Ludwigsburg gemieden die Polizei ruft
die Bevölkerung in einem Fahndungsaufruf
zur Vorsicht auf der Gewalttäter wird
vermutlich rücksichtslos von der
Schusswaffe Gebrauch machen heißt es
wörtlich die Polizei sucht den Mörder
also mit Hochdruck aber vergebens mehr
als ein halbes Jahr lang bleibt es ruhig
aber dann im Winter schlägt der Mörder
mit dem Vorschlaghammer wieder zu am 28
dezember 1984 macht der Engländer Eugene
Wetter auf der Reise in die Schweiz ein
Päuschen im Landkreis Ludwigsburg der
37-Jährige will in den Skiurlaub als
sein hellgrüner Golf auf den
Waldparkplatz heller an der Landesstraße
1115 einbiegt wartet Norbert pölke auf
sein nächstes Opfer
ein Schussfeld
Eugene ist tot ein Jogger wird den Mann
erst zwei Tage später entdecken kurz
danach wird die Volksbank-Filiale in
Cleebronn überfallen Norbert pölker
schwingt wieder den Vorschlaghammer
erbeutet 79.000 Mark und verschwindet
die Angestellten der Bank erinnern sich
an seine merkwürdige Fußstellung und
seinen Watschelgang der Wagen mit dem
Nürnberger Kennzeichen wird dann im
benachbarten Güglingen aufgefunden die
Polizei vermutet sofort dass der gleiche
Täter wie im Mai zugeschlagen hat aber
noch ist die Leiche des Engländer des
Wedding nicht gefunden als der Tote
schließlich gefunden wird entdecken die
Kriminaltechniker verstreute
sie sollten vielleicht von der
Patronenhülse ablenken die ebenfalls im
Wald liegt sie wird trotzdem gefunden
und untersucht das schockierende
Ergebnis die verwendete Hülse stammt von
polizeimunition der Täter kommt
womöglich aus den eigenen Reihen der
Ermittler diese Vermutung wird auch
durch die Tatzeiten gestützt die
Überfälle passierten jeweils zum
Schichtwechsel der Wachen gesucht wird
jetzt möglicherweise ein Polizist und in
der Öffentlichkeit nennt man den
mörderischen Bankräuber jetzt
hammermörder und das obwohl Pelke mit
seiner Pistole ermordet mit dem Hammer
ich sag mal in Anführungsstrichen nur
die Überfälle begeht jetzt läuft ein
riesen ermittlungsapparat an 12.000
baden-württembergische polizeipistolen
sollen nach und nach zum BKA nach
Wiesbaden geschickt werden damit sie mit
dem rillenabdruck der Tat Projektile
abgeglichen werden
außerdem sollen tausende Polizisten eine
Blutprobe abgeben schließlich hatte
pölke bei seinem ersten Überfall Spuren
hinterlassen als er sich an der Scheibe
die Hand verletzte man kann vieles in
Akten und Zeitungsberichten über diesen
Fall nachlesen aber was ich mich frage
wie hat sich das für pölke und seine
Familie angeführt also ich meine immer
waren die Pleite und im Jahr 84 ist dann
plötzlich andauernd genug Bargeld im
Haus
ahnt die Frau vielleicht irgendwas in
diese Richtung ist Perücke erleichtert
weil es endlich mal keine Geldsorgen
gibt oder schiebt der Panik weil so
gründlich ermittelt wird also was ist da
in den vorgegangen der Toni ich glaube
da können wir nur spekulieren denn der
Täter ist ja nicht mehr am Leben aber
auf jeden Fall hat er bei diesen
Pistolen und Blutuntersuchungen Glück im
Unglück denn der Zufall will es dass ein
Revier unter den allerletzten ist bei
diesen Maßnahmen das ganze dauert
außerdem mehrere Monate und was seine
Frau angeht die hat vielleicht schon ein
bisschen später etwas geahnt denn im
Juli 1985 wird in der Sendung
Aktenzeichen XY über den Fall berichtet
und auch über den auffälligen Gang des
Täters aber Ingeborg pölke meldet sich
nicht bei den Fahndern und Norbert pölke
der braucht wieder Geld der tragische
Fall kommt jetzt in eine wirklich
dramatische Phase am 22 juli 1985 keine
drei Wochen nach der fernsehverhandlung
ermordet er wieder
erschießt den 26-Jährigen Elektriker
Wilfried Schneider auf einem Parkplatz
zwischen den Orten Ilsfeld und Flein mit
dessen schwarzem Golf GTI macht sich
pölke auf zu Raiffeisenbank nach
spiegelberg
aber diesmal geht der anschließende
Überfall schief
als Völker maskiert in den Schalter
raumtritt ruft der Filialleiter der
Hammermann kommt Polke Schreck zurück
und flüchtet auf der Flucht wechselt er
das Fahrzeug das ist wirklich so ein
Gänsehautmoment der ein bisschen gruseln
lässt pölke Gerät nämlich mit seinem
eigenen Mercedes also in das Auto was er
gewechselt ist in eine Kontrolle
aha ein Kollege sagt der Beamte während
er pölkes Papiere durchblättert und er
warnt der Hammermann hat wieder
zugeschlagen halt dich von Parkplätzen
fern die Polizei winkt den Mörder also
durch während sie eine beispiellose
Suchaktion startet dennoch das muss man
dazu sagen ist die Leiche des
Elektrikers Schneider nicht gefunden
sie wird erst vier Tage später entdeckt
und noch ein letztes Mal hat pölke Glück
weil die Polizei verschiedene Spuren
falsch deutet nimmt sie irrtümlich den
falschen Kollegen fest es zeigt sich
aber schnell dass der Mann unschuldig
ist aber ganz Deutschland weiß jetzt
dass es sich beim Hammer Mörder um einen
Polizisten handeln soll
die Ermittlungen gehen weiter nach und
nach arbeitet die Polizei die
waffenüberprüfungen und Blutentnahmen ab
und dann Ende September 1985 ändert der
hammermörder seine Vorgehensweise er
überfällt eine kleine Bank im
dorfrosendorf zu Fuß in den ersten
Momenten vergisst er die Maske
aufzusetzen für die Flucht nimmt er sich
das Auto eines Bankkunden er erbeutet
11.000 Mark und entkommt es gibt zwar
eine recht genaue Beschreibung des
Täters von den Zeugen aber erstmals
rechnet niemand diesen Überfall dem
hammermörder zu die Vorgehensweisen
waren einfach zu unterschiedlich am Ende
ist es auch Zufall wie die Kripo dann
auf Pelke kommt
nämlich bei einer
terroristenfahndung
bei dieser terroristenfahndung werden im
Ludwigsburger Bahnhof Schließfächer
geöffnet in einem finden sich pölkes
Polizeiuniform sowie die Verpackung
einer Sturmhaube in einem Verhör erzählt
Polka den Kollegen dass er die Uniform
weggeschlossen hat weil er sie bei einer
Fahrt zum Geburtstag seiner Tante nicht
dabei haben wollte aber die Schlinge
zieht sich zu pölke soll zügig zu einer
Blutprobe erscheinen gleichzeitig ist
gerade seine Dienstwaffe bei der reinen
Untersuchung des BKA an der Reihe der
Hammer Mörder weiß dass er sehr bald
auffliegt ja zumal die ermittelnden
Kollegen nicht nur die technischen
Spuren verfolgen sondern auch sonst eins
und eins zusammenzählen das Perücke hoch
verschuldet ist z.B dass der die
polizeiprüfung erst im zweiten Anlauf
geschafft hat und erscheint jetzt Anfang
Mitte Oktober auch nicht wie angeordnet
zur Blutprobe am 18 oktober 1985
erscheint Norbert pölke nicht zum Dienst
als Beamte das Haus aufbrechen und
durchsuchen wird klar er hat seine Frau
erschossen als sie auf dem Sofa vor dem
Fernseher saß und die Leiche ins
Badezimmer geschleppt im Kinderzimmer
liegt der ältere Sohn mit einer
tödlichen schusswund im Bett Vater und
Sohn Gabriel sind nicht auffindbar denn
Norbert pölke und sein kleiner Gabriel
die sind längst unterwegs zu ihrer
letzten Reise zu der Reise nach Brindisi
wo der Vater seinen Sohn und sich selbst
am Strand erschießt und wir müssen uns
fragen hätte pölkes Familie gerettet
werden können
wenn er bei der waffenuntersuchung zum
Beispiel früher drangekommen wäre oder
bei der Blutgruppe oder wenn die Beamten
erkannt hätten dass beim letzten
Überfall auch der hammermörder am Werk
war also ich vermute das pöcke von
vornherein klar war dass es sich wenn es
irgendwann soweit kommt nicht der
Verantwortung stellen wird und was er
ganz häufig bei solchen Fällen passiert
ist dass die dann in einer
Kurzschlussreaktion
zum Mittel des erweiterten Suizids
greifen und die ganze die komplette
Familie auslöschen und als Polizist hat
er sicherlich auch die Möglichkeit
gehabt die ganze Zeit den
Ermittlungsstand weitestgehend zu
überwachen ja und ich glaube was da halt
auch mit rein spielt als Polizist geht
ja auch davon aus dass die Kollegen
jetzt nicht direkt anfangen in den
eigenen Reihen zu suchen ich kann mir
auch vorstellen dass da vielleicht so
ein bisschen
dieses erhabene vielleicht mit
reinspielt dass man denkt ich bin ja
selbst Polizist ich weiß schon wie ich
mich einstellen muss damit ich nicht so
schnell auffliege oder am besten gar
nicht auffliege das ist ihm ja dann zum
Beispiel auch durch diese Verletzung an
der Hand die dann Blutspuren
hinterlassen hat auch direkt misslungen
aber ja wie du sagst dachte
wahrscheinlich kann das noch so ein
bisschen spielen und als es dann gar
nicht mehr ging hat er dann wirklich ich
finde es immer wieder scheiße aber seine
ganze Familie mitgenommen und damit sind
wir am Ende unseres heutigen falls
angelangt ein Fall der die
Öffentlichkeit noch lange beschäftigt
hat
unter anderem hat Jurist und Autor Fred
breinersdorfer schon 1986 ein Buch dazu
veröffentlicht es gab außerdem mehrere
Verfilmungen den Fall haben wir euch mit
Artikeln aus der Stuttgarter Zeitung und
dem Landesarchiv Baden-Württemberg
erzählt
Stefan Netzeband Postproduktion durch
die weight watch Studios München wir
freuen uns wenn ihr auch beim nächsten
Mal wieder mit dabei seid eure Toni